hi everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to
simple created sim demo which I've got
an access to which is pretty cool and I
put a thing out of my Facebook page that
was like which is linked below by the
way it was like hey guys I would like to
make someone who should I make and a lot
of people suggested myself but look if
I'm being honest that is like one of the
most boring things you can make in the
sims I mean who wants to like be forced
to create their own floors and a carrot
I just don't get it man so what I'm
gonna do instead is lara croft which is
one of the suggestions I got there that
I thought was a pretty good one she kind
of looks like the same I was gonna do
like blink from Skyward soldiers that I
really wanted to do it then I realized I
knew maybe after killing some dudes but
I still feel like no no that's terrible
posture that's too excited for the stuff
law craft grows through alright alright
default will have to do pick an
aspiration
I guess athletic yeah sure and oh
knowledge on nature I mean she has to go
in nature to get knowledge but I think
she probably prefers knowledge
okay obviously if we could it go with
that no okay if I like make strange
noises it's because there's a puppy that
I'm looking after right now puppy right
here and she tends to jump up on my
computer and just mash the keyboard so
if I pulls for a moment it's because I'm
puppy maintenance Inge all right loves
see I don't know if she loves outdoors
she's just outdoors all the time I get
whoa girl loves outdoors a little bit of
a loner and you know murderer um and
she's pretty active yeah we'll go with
active Oh calm down calm down all right
so I think that's the thing that's
that's it I'm pretty sure yeah done
alright so then we just uh Hirota you
look nothing like lara croft that
canada's that looks more like Angelina
Jolie but I'm cool with it yeah she's
like a little that kind of thing I guess
that looks pretty large oh no didn't
mean to touch your lips I'm sorry that
looks pretty Lara Croft II she's a
ponytail or not oh god that was an
accident
accidentally bald story of my life right
uh accidental boldness how that's pop
there we go
it's like a Doc Brown maybe that no what
what what what is what is that even he's
not even a hair color I don't think
that's a heck oh but it is Colleen a
purple that's good hat no accessories
makeup she kind of doesn't wear any
maybe just like a little bit of a brown
I feel yeah lipstick
like that you need more of a tan I think
too like that you know what's good
all right and then we move on to your
face face bits eyebrows I'm kind of like
that that's good and I still just don't
look right so yeah so I kind of like
this feature like you can just really
pull and drag whatever you want
admittedly I'm playing this on a laptop
right now and it's a way better if you
don't have to use the trackpad because
that just makes things really
complicated nose looks pretty much
perfect lips way off though it's too big
we might get some some lip action movies
the natural but I guess that's why they
picked Angelina Jolie am i right now
that looks good okay we can like make
them smile she doesn't stop smiling no
that failed well just that's good yeah
that's good okay great
all right still something not right
about your face I think it's maybe yeah
- Shelby or something
I'm smaller eyes just looked too happy
woman I think we gotta get rid of this
makeup see if we just go push kind of
kind of still needs that Brown that
Brown you don't even change the eye
color brown they are all right let's see
if we can maybe yeah that's it that's
why because she's got some random eyes
that don't even make sense
that looks all right yeah I can do I can
do more with this kind of oh that's
weird no no no oh and bam acid and I
don't even is that wait isn't that acid
I don't know man I don't even know drugs
either way Lara Croft get off the drugs
man we just we just care about you stop
it make this Wes ridiculously baggy oh
god okay now she's like okay okay
what they thing was that color no that's
way better
how is that that code up that looks
oranged me how is that that what okay no
I mean that's that's totally makes sense
and then we'll make you just because
he's supposed to be dirty
yeah you just look really tan - now why
don't you look like a lot of crafts yet
you need ice what I used to be most
elections than this thing alright it's
good it's good okay
face is still kinda needs to be slim on
is okay okay maybe section Oh God
puppies trying to get on the couch I
could die
just like every white girls nose fo I
mean I can't really work with that
miscellaneous white girl knows except
that my nose is like no no like that
every white girl but me no I'm kidding
I feel like we're doing well I feel like
this is this is pretty Laura crufty I
can really do much else to a face yes
like everything else is pretty good new
we can not all right that's good that's
gonna it's gonna have to do it not
totally lara croft ii but it'll have to
do okay buddy time this is what stuff
gets weird
alright you kind of she's kind of thin
right pretty sure our craft is filled
you just got me just make you she's
gonna be surely kind of muscly but
that's that looks right but i but if I
like remove that top that's just gonna
be terrifying give you some kind of
short top so I can see how ripped your
abs are yeah
see maybe Lara would look like that like
she yes she probably would hey like the
amount of climbing but she does you'd
have to have a pretty strong cool right
totally
and then her legs would be like a little
bit bigger the chest part is just so can
you imagine if I made myself and like
well obviously the chest needs to be
let's see that's I just shouldn't have
done that
though it seems about right I feel like
everything that looks pretty accurate
legs don't look tiny tiny tiny legs okay
then look I do not know what Lara
Croft's butt looks like but I wonder if
you can make what changes oh my gosh
yeah I feel like it's probably my god
but so like medium medium but silly crap
feel good about this alright maybe yeah
looks good okay so we need to give you
like a tank but not any of these maybe
that one if I can do it in like a boiler
that's not terrible I mean it's not
great either because once again in its
different it's not different
alright but yeah once again like in the
other sims creator Sam you could do way
more stuff so because this isn't
technically a final version I don't know
how much of this stuff you're gonna be
able to do like you'd be able to change
the color and stuff so I don't even want
a tank I just want to go down to singlet
really but I think that's probably the
closest I can get okay bottoms please
Gene's bird and they're like greeny none
of these are good this is not what I
want at all
okay we get greeny just one cocky man
come on this is just not Lara Croft
maybe if we do four more it'll change
things
yeah no I'm not at all okay well this is
not going according to plan we could
just make the floral making sense kind
of that not all right we're gonna have
to go with I think the orange I'm sorry
that's good so like you do and then yeah
the rest the stuff you got here is
formal no formal jeans so you can you
know mess with this kind of stuff yeah
it's just like that would do Lara Croft
just fine why did you make it look like
Lady gaga that just doesn't make sense
what you gonna sleep in
Stryper you there you go
cute sure whatever
yeah I wear that to a party so then I
guess that's everything actually that is
that is gonna have to be Lara Croft I'm
pretty happy with her face outfit not so
much hang on shoes I go adventuring in
boots like those that actually makes it
look a bit more authentic and
I guess that's it's gonna be everything
that is my attempt at law Croft thank
you for everyone who suggested things on
my Facebook page even the people who
suggested Justin Bieber for whatever
reason again link to that is below if
you want to check it out if if people
enjoy this one I kind of liked the
challenge I might you know ask people
again sometime if you guys don't want to
see another one cuz the game doesn't
come out until September sometime and I
guess then if I just go hang oh yeah who
needs a name anyway that's really good
she's all done and that's the happiest
you'll ever see her so let's go with
that that looks better
alright I hope you guys enjoyed this
video I am charlie on Azad and I will
see you guys next time